is there something that we're missing
that you something that you 100
wholeheartedly believe if there's
something that the audience
can kind of grasp and be like all right
this is what this guy stands for other
than hey i don't know what i don't know
is there something that you
totally affirm and stand by uh
religiously sure
what is that i'm not going to say
how what do you mean you're not going to
say why should i confide the innermost
secrets of my heart to an ambassador why
we have you on here today are you
serious with that everyone has something
everyone has something locked away about
which he has a certain emotional
attitude
but it's a very very little interest to
anyone else is the question is there
anything about which i'm certain the
answer is sure that's what i want to
know for example i'm certain that
mathematics
to the extent that it's demonstrable is
true
i think there are
certain very sophisticated questions you
can ask about truth and proof and
mathematics but those are not the
questions i'm asking i think the body of
mathematical knowledge accumulated
early part of the 21st century is the
richest body of human knowledge ever
accumulated followed very closely by the
body of knowledge encapsulated in
theoretical physics i'm really certain
those are those are achievements
much less certain about lots of other
things
certain about
the existence
as every man is certain about the
existence of certain attitudes
validities
commitments
which make no sense to anyone else
but in answer to your original question
my indifference had a lot to do with
watching the experience of my parents
a lot to do both my parents grew up in
germany
imperial germany and then weimar germany
and they both always said they were
children of the weimar republic
they began um music lessons at the age
of six and both became professional
musicians my father was a concert
pianist in central europe my mother was
an excellent pianist
and they both
reported to me very early in my
childhood their defiance of jewish
orthodoxy how they both told the rabbi
well they just didn't believe in god not
the god of the jewish tradition in any
rate the god they preferred to embrace
was the god of art
especially music and they were heirs to
the entire rich complex tradition of
german
german music musical experience
and they enriched that tradition when
they moved to france and they learned
about the french musical tradition
and the question that always
influenced me in my childhood was
watching
this commitment and asking myself is
this an adequate substitute
for a classical theological
understanding of the universe could some
and it's it's by no means restricted to
my parents i think everyone from that
milieu
intellectuals writers artists musicians
attempted from 1910 to 1940 or so to
find a substitute god
a substitute experience which would have
the same compelling moral and
intellectual force as a classical
religious experience
toward the end of my life
end of my parents lives it occurred to
me in my life as well the last stages um
that that experiment was a failure
that the god in which they had invested
so much emotional and autistic energy
was not really a substitute at all and
that was a sobering experience
that i realized in the end music failed
them both
it didn't provide what they really
needed
and i think that's a very common
experience when you turn
to uh
deep powerful currents
and you
try to identify them the way many
contemporary intellectuals do when they
talk about humanism for example
as substitutes
for discarded tradition
the discovery i suspect is almost
inevitable
that the substitute is pretty much like
a sugar substitute
it may taste sweet
but it leaves a very bitter aftertaste
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you